[Music]
hello and welcome to this video yeah
this video is about all the
continuations after E 4 E 5 9003
where black does not go for ninety six
after ninety six we play Knight c3 and
we were heading to the squad for Knights
which is a separate chapter so this is
yeah the the rest let's say that can
happen after Knight f3 we have a wide
range of options to look at Black has
tried many moves them actually most of
them are not that great but there are
two respectable options the most
respectable moves are the petrov or
russian defense Knight to f6 a
symmetrical response and the second
fairly good move is d6 the philidor's
defense those two are fairly yeah
regardless fairly solid options for
black that are fully playable the
philidor's may be a little bit less so
than the petrov which is a main defense
of many world-class players d6 is viewed
as somewhat second-rate but not terrible
food blankets are fully fully playable
all the other moves however at least
slightly dubious we still should have a
look at them because again some of those
moves we can expect to get even more
than a usual opening edge in some cases
even positions that are downright
winning or clearly better so I suggest
to start with the more dubious options
and then work towards the more
respectable ones
one of the most dubious ways for black
to play here is the move F
the so-called Latvian gambit this is
basically a Kings gambit tempo down we
have them is ninety of three extra
compared to the King's gambit and this
opening is basically not working it is
just notoriously murky and then the
positions are somewhat unconventional
and weird and most likely the black
player who's surprising you with this
move will know it better or will have
looked at it while you probably study it
once here on chess to go and then never
get it on the board or very rarely get
it on the board so still be be cautious
and young to be alert because it is
notoriously as I mentioned murky but it
is very good for what so what are we
going to do we take e5 of course you
know taking a center pawn is always
almost always a good idea yeah what does
black now do there is only one move that
makes this whole thing somewhat
interesting that is the move Queen to f6
attacking the knight and at the same
time I'm preparing against Queen h5
check which is an idea of course and we
this is wide open
a move that is surprisingly tricky is
Knight to c6 we should look at this
first
now after knight c6 it is very strange
but it is the case that Queen h5 which
looks perfectly normal is not entirely
clear after g6 Knight XG 6:9 f6 we don't
need to deal with this so much the only
thing that you need to remember about
ninety six is that the best move is d4
we simply keep this night covered with
deform and continue to develop
I had this move once knight c6 played
against me in a simultaneous display and
back at the time I did not I had not
checked the Latvian for a long time
and I had forgotten about d4 and I
actually took on c6 which wasn't that
clear
after d4 White is clearly better and you
don't need to know much more like it
doesn't really have a decent move
available now what exactly should he
play his King is wide open and if we
develop we just will be better the move
Queen to f6 is more critical after that
white has two main options Knight to c4
or D for both the d2 Oakley advantage
I'm going for d4 him d6 you know it's
probably what what black will do here
with Knight has to retreat and now black
takes so after Knight c3 we see that
black only has the Queen and play and
has efore under attack no the point is
hanging on e4 black goes Queen g6
protecting the pawn and here we see a
very typical approach against murky
gambits we play a three we're not trying
to and win additional material or
whatever our goal is now to use our
better development because this kind of
playful like it's not really developing
pieces so an f3 we open everything up
black takes it mostly they will take it
and after Queen takes our position is
excellent now we have two nights out and
while black has no minor piece developed
and Bishop d3 will be a useful tempo to
come it's very very nice
instead black could play Knight f6 to
cover the pawn but after F takes e4 it
cannot recapture as Bishop d3 is a
lethal pin on the knight blacks position
is extremely shaky and the Latvian if
you play it correctly but again it is
sometimes a bit murky it's weird
attention has vias weird position so
yeah try to be still very much lured
against and the dubious opening like the
but it is a lot better for white
objectively speaking um there are quite
a number of dubious gambit so that can
happen in the open games and one of them
that is what we're going to look at next
is the move d5 the elephant gambit yeah
really funny opening name but you know
every absolutely every opening that is
named after an animal is bad and this is
also the case for the elephant gambit
okay what are we going to do we take the
pawn of course and here black mostly has
tried to move the movie for to attack
our light or the move Bishop d6 we can
start with Bishop d6 which covers ePHI
for the moment yeah I suggest to simply
play D form after which is the only way
to somehow justify what black is doing
is to push a form in after 95 I see
absolutely no compensation for the pawn
I mean while it's just a pawn up and
what exactly is the compensation we will
just develop our pieces and what is
Apollo and I don't see what it what
black has a bit more interesting if we
go back is to move efore because then at
least it takes our Knight you know and
we we have to do something about it the
next couple of moves I in fact important
to remember because if you play
somewhere else black would be fine for
example if you move the knight
yeah black Isis is very okay and like
here Quinn takes and we have to lose
tempo with Tampa with the night that
wouldn't be anything anything good for
us but much better is the move Queen to
e2 this is something that you need to
remember it's a little bit of an
unnatural looking move but it is strong
because it pins the pawn the king and we
threatening just to take it and that is
the start of forcing play um black
protects the pawn very logical and after
d3 we increase the play
shun it yeah black will take 25 yes the
only move that makes any sense and now
it's an interesting moment in fact if we
play the natural looking move Knight c3
I can put it on the board just to show
what I mean
Black has bishop before and this pin
it's actually not that terrible for him
yeah Black is somewhat okay here I like
a different approach which is much
simpler to handle if we go back we can
play this move from that B to d2 and
this way avoid any Bishop before pin now
we just detect for so often that black
will not be able to defend it yeah this
is already yeah looking quite really
comfort like a if it just lose before
what's the deal I hope you enjoyed this
preview of the keep it simple
efore repertoire you can get the full
course on chasuble comm which features
the move trainer that makes it easy and
simple to learn all the nice and
remember them all Knights are chosen
with one thing in mind keep it simple
for you
and make it difficult for your opponent
[Music]
you